let's get some analysis now from the
outside advisor to President Trump for
judicial nominations
Leonard Leo joins us tonight Leonard
thanks for being here good to be here
first put this in perspective about how
big a deal this opening not just a
opening this opening is sure Justice
Kennedy has been on the courts for over
30 years and he's played an enormous ly
important role in helping to fashion so
many different areas of our
jurisprudence from gun rights to freedom
of speech separation of powers
federalism it's a big deal the process
I'm being kind of whispers that the Neel
Gorsuch blueprint is basically what is
going to move forward yes the president
had enormous success in nominating Neel
Gorsuch to the court and I think that's
the kind of process that you'll see
going forward another nominee like him
is the sense you heard the sound of
Majority Leader that this is going to
happen quickly is there a timeline on
this usually it takes the White House
about two or three weeks to get a
nomination out and then normally it
takes about 72 a hundred days for a
Senate to confirm so the leaders right
you're looking at the fall and you could
have somebody seated just before the
beginning of the october term of the
court or just after it starts what about
the the democrats including the Senate
Minority Leader were out there saying
this can't happen that needs to wait
till after the election
president appoints justices to the court
it's one thing to say that you know just
before presidential election we should
have a cooling-off period but we have a
president the American people knew he
was going to who he was going to
nominate because he gave him a list so
we should just move forward and he's
saying that this list is unacceptable
but in reality because of the vote
structure in the Senate there's really
nothing Senate Democrats can do is there
to stop a nomination from going forward
aside from tripping that person up in a
hearing if the president nominates
someone extraordinary like Neil Gorsuch
again I think it's very hard to stop
that kind of a nomination the American
people were widely supportive of neo
Gorsuch and justice Gorsuch had
bipartisan support in the Senate okay
let's talk about a couple of the names
that we're hearing about already John
mentioned some of them Judge Brett
Kavanaugh
see Circuit US Court of Appeals here in
Washington very distinguished service on
the federal bench hundreds of opinions
published out of the DC Circuit someone
who understands that those limits on
government power and our Constitution
are inextricably intertwined with the
preservation of freedom in our country
well he have problems with Democrats
well as Senator Schumer's said anyone
the president nominates will have
problems with Democrats but ultimately I
think we're at state Democrats and
moderates and the Senate will understand
that someone like Brett Kavanaugh or
another neil core such type nominee
would be quite suitable for our country
he was a top official in the george w
bush white house yes let's talk about
judge thomas Hardiman Third Circuit US
Court of Appeals chambers in Pittsburgh
judge Hartmann was someone who the
president actually interviewed the first
time around and again someone who's been
on the bench quite a while very
extensive record seeing lots of cases
someone again who understands that it's
the job of a judge to interpret the laws
it's written speaking of those laws just
recently 5-4 rulings in which Kennedy
was in the majority you have union dues
just out today Trump travel ban abortion
language specifics Texas redistricting
state sales tax Ohio voter roll purge
just to name a few recently but he's
been swing vote on a lot of major cases
is the fear on the Left justified that
this means that roe v wade is in
jeopardy if one of the 25 gets through
the process the left has been using the
roe v-- wade scare tactic since 1982
when Sandra O'Connor was nominated and
over 30 years later nothing's happened
to roe v wade and the fact of the matter
is we know as much about a number of the
justices for example John Roberts as we
knew about Justice Kennedy was when he
was nominated so I think the ROE bortion
issue is really very much a scare tactic
this is needs to be about the
Constitution more broadly as you pointed
out Kennedy has been very important in
propelling jurisprudence in lots of
different areas of the law and that's
what this process should examine let's
take a listen to
Justice Kennedy about the Constitution
it is appropriate to recognize an
essential truth and that is that the
Constitution of the United States is the
single fact the single reality the
single idea the single moral principle
that sets the United States apart from
other nations now and throughout history
I shall honor the Constitution nominated
in 1988 by President Reagan Justice
Kennedy made this decision went and
talked to President Trump do you know
anything about those conversations I
understand that it was a very cordial
conversation the president was very
impressed with him his graciousness the
30 years plus a service he had on the
court you know the Trump's and the
Kennedys as a fan as families have known
each other over the years on and off so
I think it was very gracious for the
Justice to go to the White House and
talk directly to the president talk
about names I don't know if they did but
Justice Kennedy is a very prudent and
discreet man so I suspect that you know
he understands the role that he plays in
the role the president place do you
think this will have an effect
politically and not where you are you're
looking at the justices and and who's
going to be nominated the judges but as
you look at the political landscape that
this could have a big impact any any
vacancy on the court does the court
these days make so many important
decisions that affect American life that
it ought to be an important part of the
political process people ought to think
seriously about who they want on the
court and I do suspect it will have some
impact in the Senate election process in
2016 all voters conservatives and
independents ranked it pretty high for
the reason that they chose to vote as
they should as they should
Leonard Leo we'd love to have you back
as this process gets gets moving it's
good to see you again thank you thank
you brain